[Music]
foreign
river system provides water to 40
million people across the west from
Denver to LA to Mexico but after more
than two decades of drought water levels
have reached historic lows and
competition for the remaining water
between countries between states even
between neighbors is growing Fierce
Brook Silva Braga traveled to one
Arizona community that could lose access
to the Colorado within weeks
drive just north of Scottsdale and
you'll find a loose grid of dirt roads
known as the Rio Verde Foothills two
thousand homes enjoying rustic desert
Beauty and the freedom of living outside
the city limits but Rio Verde now finds
itself at the center of the West's
growing Water Crisis I never thought I
would actually be in a position where
this community it could crumble
John and Horn newer moved here 23 years
ago discovered his new community didn't
have water service and stumbled onto a
new career the wells in my area are
questionable at best so I just opted to
grab a trailer and haul my own water and
then did someone say hey could you grab
some for me exactly because my neighbors
saw me coming up the road of the trailer
they're like hey if you stop and drop
off a load for me once every four to six
weeks tops off my tank more than a
quarter of Rio Verde relies on hauled
water and the tank actually runs from
here to over here Karen nabity bought
here in 2014. yeah we had talked to a
lot of neighbors and they've been doing
it for 50 years and it wasn't a big deal
we weren't concerned about it at that
time but times have changed as the
Colorado River system has dried up the
pipe where horn newer gets water belongs
to the city of Scottsdale and after
years of warning Rio Verde they should
find another source in six weeks on
January 1st Scottsdale is cutting off
water to Rio Verde I expected to live
out here for the rest of my life and now
I actually question whether here is
going to be there the rest of my life
poor newer can make a two-hour round
trip to another source but it's so far
away state law might not allow it a
regional water utility says it has a
solution but needs at least two years
before it will be ready so maybe
Scottsdale will just keep the pipe open
here's Scottsdale mayor David Ortega why
not just let those few people keep the
water for a little longer they should
manage their own destiny with their own
water right now they are truck and water
burning diesel to supply themselves
which we do not support they're about to
burn more diesel because they're gonna
have to truck it from farther away
that's their problem
Scottsdale has its own problem the
northern part of the city gets 90
percent of its water from the shrinking
Colorado the constant decline of the
water source is reality yeah we have to
adapt and then we have to adapt more and
we have to adapt more to understand what
faces the West consider some basic math
by law seven states in Mexico are
allocated in total 16 and a half million
acre feet of Colorado River water each
year but these days only about 11
million acre feet are actually flowing
and so the big collection points of the
River Lake Mead and Lake Powell are
draining like bathtubs if you look out
two years Lake Powell could go so low
um that is essentially dry Tom bashatsky
runs Arizona's water department what
that would mean if we hit that is no
water in the river through the Grand
Canyon for starters he says temporary
drastic cuts are needed to stabilize the
system but even then the reduced flow of
the river is unlikely to change it's
still snowing and raining
80 90 100 percent of what it did
historically but instead of that turning
into water that goes into the river the
water's disappearing wait what does that
mean where is it going we're getting 40
or 60 percent of that water going into
the river so in 90 of the snowfall 40
percent of the water and so it's
happening because the soil is much drier
because it's been hotter the snow is
melting sooner and trees and other
vegetation are growing earlier in the
year because of the warming climate and
it's probably the single biggest
challenge that we have in managing the
river moving into the future but the
water is not coming back it is highly
unlikely this summer the federal
government asks the states to sort out a
deal to cut out as much as a quarter of
their use the states couldn't agree the
water rights have a legal pecking order
in California which uses the most has
the right to take its Cuts last
meanwhile Arizona has built
infrastructure to store extra water
underground and is banked a few years
worth so why would they take voluntary
cuts when they could just be banking
more for the future and so it really
complicates the ability to do something
collaboratively on the one hand
situation is not good on the other hand
the politics of truly addressing it are
just real hard
yes they are that that's a good summary
of all of it consider the politics of
water pricing a fraction of a cent per
gallon even in the desert yet rate
increases face major opposition or the
politics of construction in Rio Verde
even Lots with no water are still
guaranteed building permits by the
pro-growth state government and consider
the politics of lawns in Scottsdale even
though most residential water is used
outside the home the same city cutting
the tap to neighboring Rio Verde hasn't
issued any watering restrictions on
itself but none of that would solve the
problem not even cutting off all water
to every home in Arizona would solve the
problem because 70 percent of the
state's water is used for farming
Farmers want to be here and they're
going to do everything they possibly can
to hang on and stay here but the
politics of cutting water to Farmers
like Nancy K wood aren't easy either in
many cases they have the oldest water
rights in the region and have already
been taking Cuts we don't want to start
depending on other countries for our
food and fiber even understanding that
it does seem like there might be another
part of the country where it'd be easier
and maybe even more sensible to grow
crops go try to plant your your lettuce
cabbage cauliflower all those winter
crops in Minnesota nobody's going to get
salads you know this all takes us back
to the Tangled politics of Rio Verde
according to Maricopa County Supervisor
Thomas Galvin a temporary solution has
been found the utility company epcor
could send water through Scottsdale
system for Rio Birdie's use the catch is
Scottsdale needs to agree we just hope
that mayor Ortega can help these folks
in a spirit of cooperation now that the
solution has been found to facilitate it
I am not equivocating that's not going
to happen they'll to add another
thousand homes out there they'll think
well Scottsdale has got to be
compassionate and give us the that's not
good enough they're going to have to
find their own solution is there any
solution that doesn't involve Scottsdale
letting you use their standpipe
um at the moment no so six more weeks of
water for 500 American homes with more
being built even as the pipe runs dry do
you anticipate there being other
communities like that facing this in the
years ahead based on the Pioneer
attitude that still exists in Arizona
it's going to continue to happen for CBS
Saturday morning Brook silver bracket
just outside Scottsdale Arizona
something here in the Northeast we take
for granted water right and you don't
think about it and what a big deal and
it's been a big deal for a long long
time obviously water issues in the west
but 500 people you don't have water I
remember being a huge deal in California
I just am thinking what Brook said it
was this lose-lose proposition of you
can't get along you can't decide to do
this how do you make it the end result
is there's not enough water to go around
right so we got to find a solution so
let's cooperate with one well there
might there might be enough it just yeah
it's the cooperation cooperation part
yeah